we had the very unfortunate situation of
having a guest canceled on us last
minute and so we are going to pick up on
a few phone calls and see what's on
people's minds you can call in at 6 1 7
8 3 0 47 50 let's go to our caller from
the 2 6 0 caller from 2 6 0 what's your
name where you calling from hi this is
Joanna I have a family member who is a
libertarian mm-hmm and can you can you
hear me okay oh yeah okay so I like
really want medicare-for-all and I talk
about it a lot with them and they their
argument is like well why would you want
to give the government even more control
because they're here they want a small
government and the only thing like I can
come up with is like well you know if
Congress had to have the same you know
health care that we did they make sure
that it was like awesome but I didn't
know like what else I could tell them to
like get them on board with Medicare
girl yeah I mean listen you're probably
not going to be able to get them on
board with Medicare for all I think that
the the extreme libertarian position is
one of the hardest ones to kind of bring
over to the side of wanting the
government to do things because they see
the government stepping out as good they
see the government not being involved as
virtuous regardless of the outcome even
if what the free market ends up putting
together is inferior in some way they
don't want the government involved and
believe the government can't do anything
the reality is that the government is
not objectively bad at doing things it
the the problem is that we often have a
disagreement as to what different people
believe our tax money should go to and
we end up having too much money going to
certain things like the military the
Pentagon defense weapons military
industrial complex etc and not enough
going towards things like health care
now a
as far as cost goes other countries
where the government is more involved in
healthcare spend less per person and
have better outcomes so if their concern
is that they don't think the government
would do a good job
there's many counter examples that could
be given if their concern is that it's
going to cost too much well then you can
talk to them about the cost programs
that are very reasonable in terms of
what something like this would cost if
they simply ideologically don't want the
government doing stuff that's going to
be oh you're gonna hit a brick wall
there I don't know what you could say
mmm gotcha
yeah that's helpful um because they you
know they obviously you know believe the
government is corrupt and they agree
with me that health care should not be
for profit and so I'm like oh that's why
you don't want like private companies in
charge of health care because their
whole goal is to generate profit as much
profit as possible yeah I mean companies
the the industry in the u.s. is
regulated in a way that actually sort of
limits the percentage that health
insurance companies can profit but just
because we're talking about it there are
other systems like for example one where
the government you still have non
government insurance companies they have
to be non-profit companies and they are
heavily regulated by the government and
the government still acts sometimes as a
payor like there's all sorts of
different plans you can look at what
France does Germany Switzerland there's
lots of different ideas but again if
it's just an ideological barrier it can
be tough to talk to libertarians hmm all
right thank you so much I appreciate it
all right Joanna I appreciate the call
thank you so much